let's jump to the story real quick from
The Verge Nike just bought a virtual
shoe company that makes nfts and
sneakers for the metaverse now why do I
bring up metaverse in this context we're
talking about finance and inflation and
prices my friends hear me now the
metaverse is going to happen maybe not
Mark zuckerbergs but there will be a
metaverse and it's already happening
apparently apparently a couple just got
married in the metaverse
cryptocurrency will likely be the
currency and tracking mechanism by which
you own
to us whatever to whatever extent you
can own a digital piece of property now
when they say you'll own nothing and
you'll be happy
in that world economic Forum video or
that article they're talking about
physical objects but I I genuinely
believe the singularity will happen I
believe that uh Bitcoin is is going to
be a currency for this new digital world
nfts are going to be how you own unique
objects in this in this new virtual
reality and this is where everyone is
being pushed towards with the collapse
of the US economy and the crisis we're
seeing more and more people are being
told why don't you get cryptocurrencies
I mean we advocate for the stuff we
don't tell you any advice but we love we
you know I'm I'm a big advocate for it
but let's be real a universal Glo a a a
global digital trackable monetary system
there's a lot of things bad about that
idea you'll be able to see how who has
how much money publicly see how much
money a person has when they spend it
and where it goes now of course there is
what zcash and Monero I believe make it
much much more difficult so other
cryptos will emerge but here's what I
see with all of this you're not going to
get Mark Zuckerberg nuking other
companies and stealing a name if he
wasn't dead set on doing it you wouldn't
see Nike buying a company that makes
virtual shoes you wouldn't see this big
push while we are all discussing and
debating things like January 6 and
anti-fund Street violence I think the
real push from the elites what they
really want is to get everybody in some
kind of metaverse some kind of digital
internet-based reality where they're
more easily controlled where they're
less likely to produce I'm sorry pollute
or fight there'll be less conflict
conflict will be digital and it's going
to be like that episode of Black Mirror
that's that's the inner Universe we're
heading towards and this I think shows
it's happening so I've been talking
about Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies for a
very long time and I remember
interviewing Max Kaiser back in the
early 2010s when Bitcoin was first
hitting the world staged and I was like
in in London uh and I was talking to Max
was walking with him I was like how do
we know that Bitcoin isn't the one world
global government currency that they've
been waiting to push on to everyone
where they could track trace and
database everyone on a public Ledger I
know everything that everyone is doing
and um I forgot Max Kaiser's response I
gotta watch my old videos in order to
see that but whether it's Bitcoin or
another government coin we know Russia
is working on their own kind of
cryptocurrency so is Venezuela where of
course there'll be less protections for
personal freedoms and Liberties right
now if you have a Bitcoin address it's
as private as as much as uh anyone else
who knows about it so if no one knows
that I have a Bitcoin address there
could be money coming out in and out no
one would know it unless I publicly tell
someone I have a Bitcoin so it might be
Bitcoin it might be another currency but
there are other people using this
technology to push privacy coins push
for people to have total anonymity
online total freedom total privacy and
it's it's a double-edged sword I think
cryptocurrencies it's the new internet
and I think just like it could be used
for something really bad and really evil
and and total government control I think
it'll it could also be used for
something that could Free People
liberate people and give them privacy
which is absolutely essential in our
modern day Society I think it I I think
it's great I think bitcoin's fantastic
but I do think it's going to be an
excellent tool cryptocurrencies the
blockchain in the upcoming metaverse and
digital worlds whether intentional or
not it's happening let's let's pull up
this story real quick and we'll add to
the conversation Florida couple holds
virtual wedding in the metaverse while
simultaneously getting married in real
life complete with avatars that mimicked
their exact moves for their online
guests
it's not that crazy an idea I think
people look at this and they don't
understand the context there's a lot of
people who couldn't travel to be at the
wedding so they did a virtual version so
you can put on your Oculus or whatever
and watch it happen I don't think
virtual reality in the metaverse is all
bad I just think that there are creepy
Elites who want to take away your
possessions and your ability to work and
make money and stick you in a box where
you have no kids and then you rot and
suffer I think there's a lot of really
bad things about the elites one
Technology's not all bad though however
I do think we are advancing in a creepy
Direction and this may actually just be
a fad
I do believe we are more likely to be
heading into a metaverse singularity
type of reality where we're brain
shipped by Elon Musk in the next year
that's what he's saying he's saying next
year the chips are going to be available
to put in people and and do all this
stuff and I do think there's going to be
a big push for this but we also heard
what 12 years ago or 14 years ago that
Vera chip people are going to be getting
chips and planted in their hands and
that never really took off now we did
see in Sweden people are getting the
chip Chips implanted in their skin under
their skin that contains their covet
information and they walk up to doors
and they can stand it but that's the
same thing we saw 14 years ago it just
did not happen people were not
interested in it now is that going to be
the same thing with the metaverse that
it's this big fad Mark Zuckerberg dumps
all this money and effort into it and
then everyone says yo we don't want to
do your stupid virtual reality thing or
are we forced into it but I would I I'll
just quickly say that we don't have a
microchip in our hand but we have a
phone in our hands almost everywhere we
go and some people say that the
microchip was replaced by the phone
which essentially almost acts like the
same thing another thing I would just
want to to quickly add before going to
uen is that the metaverse is an excuse
to put people into the smart grids in
major cities and into the social credit
scores that's how I see it from a lot of
the elitist perspectives on what they
want to achieve with it sorry Ian go
ahead
um oh the difference I think uh between
what was what we're talking about
chipping your hands yeah is that the
body people don't like inserting things
inside themselves if they can that's not
true Ian well they don't I don't
most people don't would opt to put on
the hat instead of inject the needle
into their into their Temple yeah um I
know what you meant I'm just saying an
adult joke oh Tim uh
I had a comment lined up and I was like
okay like whereas the body can reject
things that you insert into it
um whereas the metaverse is just more of
like a spiritual technological Evolution
bro have you guys played with the Oculus
a little bit not yet there's a game
called like Pirate Space robot or
something space pirate trainer it's so
good dude it's so good man it's crazy so
that was holding the Oculus or or the VR
back for a while right was that the
technology wasn't that good and now it's
good you're saying it's been good for a
few years yes
that's big it's it's yeah it's wireless
it uses like IR tracking and so uh to
Ian's Point yeah I think you're correct
in that regard there's um did you know
that you can give yourself an additional
sense yeah now it's not people say
there's five senses or whatever that's
not true humans have way more than five
senses like people don't count a sense
of balance sense of temperature but you
can actually take neodymium magnets and
implant them under your fingertips and
then give yourself Electro perception or
Electro sense so what happens is the
magnets will be in your finger and I I
personally know people who have done
this and when you move your hand and
passed a a power cable in a wall front
so let's say let's say there's a wall
and trying to find out where the cable
is if you have an embedded neodymium
magnet in your finger you can feel the
electric fields in your fingertips
giving yourself Electro sense by doing
this the problem is the body rejects the
magnet after a certain amount of time it
it breaks and your body pushes it out
through your skin and it falls out yeah
I heard a lot of stories about dogs that
were microchipped getting uh you know
infections and diseases and Cancers in
near wherever they had the microchip
injected those are some of the stories
that I saw on the internet even just a
few years ago so it wouldn't surprise me
if they transitioned from you know let's
inject it to let's just have him have it
everywhere they go including when they
go poop then how is Elon Musk going to
implant the computer chips did they
figure this out have you seen have you
seen the neuraling stuff well the monkey
yeah very surgery very thin copper wires
that make contact so maybe that is too
small to get rejected maybe it just sits
you know thread them into like the outer
layer of the brain they like carve out
like a quarter sized hole in the skull
and then they thread like I don't know a
thousand Tiny Little Fibers into like
the the top layer of the brain and then
the that gives the impulses ideally
they're gonna evolve it so that they
don't have to cut the the scalp the
skull open or insert anything some
people are saying they're gonna do it
like Teeth uh teeth implants that's
another possibility but some people even
reject a tooth implants some people
can't have them because their body just
says no I don't want it and those will
be the uh the the deplorables yeah well
all the people are gonna be you know
synced up in society and they're going
to be part of the network they're gonna
be like the Borg and there's going to be
people who are like outside begging for
for scraps because they're not gonna be
able to work I cannot bring myself to
drill a hole in my head for this is that
what it says that that looks like a
whole it's not a quarter size maybe like
a dime or smaller now if I was paralyzed
and this could help me walk or if I was
blind and it could help me see it's
another we should look up the monkey
because because Elon Musk did this to
the monkey that was using his brain chip
to play a video game with the monkey's
own mind would you take the chip
again I guess if Ian was saying like if
the calculation had changed if I was if
I happen to be paralyzed or had some
horrible disability that could be fixed
with norlink I think I would be very
much willing to give it a shot I mean
what what do you have to lose if you're
confined to a wheelchair and and you
know this company says that hey we might
be able to make you walk but that's the
that's the pr public excuse they're
going to use for Total Domination and a
track trace and database Society where
they're the tech overlords of our
existence and we're the peon slaves so
on that note I do have to say that as
someone who requires kind of expensive
medicine I don't hate big Pharma as much
as some people and as someone who may
ultimately end up requiring something
that will keep me from being in a
wheelchair I have to say this stuff is
kind of exciting I'm not gonna probably
voluntarily sign up for neuralink but
they when they were researching some of
these mRNA vaccines they found some
interesting new treatments for whatever
it is that I have and I was like that's
really neat so you never know where
there's going to be in advance and I was
going to say one of the things that I'm
sure they're probably thinking about
right now is how your body is going to
respond to keeping this inside your body
because you can't even transplant an
organ without requiring anti-rejection
medicine for the rest of your life
because your body does not want any
foreign objects in it at all like your
body rejects tattoo ink your body
rejects everything maybe this is why
they're working so hard towards
artificial intelligence because the
human mind is not programmed it is
developed over a period of time and
itself generates it's it there's like a
base code when human is born and over
time the neurons connect and each
individual's brain function is unique
like a brain print almost so how do you
affect how do you interface with a brain
that is unique to itself self-grown when
we make a computer we take the schematic
for the computer we replicate it a
billion times there's our computer we
know how they work they have
interchangeable parts but each
individual human is not the same some
people use a slightly different part of
the brain it grew a different position
artificial intelligence may be able to
rapidly map out the key areas of the
brain so it can interface very very
quickly yeah it also looks like that
monkey went through surgery like they
opened up his skull and Implement
implemented a chip in there because you
don't see any wires on the outside you
see a bald spot on the back of the
monkey's head so it looks like this and
it showed this surgery it showed the
implant being injected after a cut of
the monkey's head so check this out
check this out in the beginning you can
see the monkeys using a joystick and
then I guess later on they get rid of
the joystick now it's just controlling
it with his brain ah crazy is he blowing
on something or sucking on something I
think it's giving him food or something
okay no I I don't know maybe we should
just watch it and they'll tell us what
he's doing yeah and then Elon Musk is
looking at human trials in 2022. so next
year he's looking at human beings being
these monkeys literally uh testing out
the brain chips here's one here's what I
want to know you're gonna be able to
type with your thoughts yeah you're just
gonna think a sentence and it's going to
be on the page that's right but let me
let me let me ask everybody especially
for use uh for for use guys who are uh
watching the show because I don't
there's a lot of people who I think are
absolutely craving and Desiring this
begging for it and it's probably a lot
of people who won't admit it because
that's what I was saying to uh when we
had Jack Murphy on the show I was like
imagine you get up you walk over to your
treadmill you throw the towel over your
neck you turn on your neural link and
then all of a sudden you're at Old
Country Buffet
and while you are virtually
consuming massive quantities of food and
cakes and steaks filet mignon all the
steak you can eat you're sitting there
eating and then you get full and you're
like that was awesome take off the
neural link and you're running on the
treadmill and you stop and you've been
running for an hour you're all sweaty
and fit and actually and you weren't
even in that you know you weren't doing
the chore of the excess no I think it's
fair to point a lot of people like
exercise but some people don't and so
Jack was like oh man you're making the
tempting or whatever there's a lot of
people and and beyond that too what if
you could take you know you've got the
brain chip and then you could take a
little chip that was like you know uh
Elder Scrolls 13. put it on your on your
brain turn it boom you're just you're in
Elder Scrolls you're fighting dragons
you're throwing Fireballs they're gonna
need to make Elder Scrolls 15 cream that
I can just rub on my floor on my third
eye and then I'll then I'll install it
and I'll install the game for me you
snort it yeah I don't wanna I don't want
to insert anything but also you know
sacrifice and pain builds character and
and Builds an appreciation for something
if you're just given something I mean
obviously the average human being is
going to like it for a little bit but
then become kind of apathetic to it and
not be happy not be satisfied because
they never truly worked for something
that's their own it was just given to
them in this kind of metaverse and I
think this is going to create a society
of very unhappy people and I don't think
it's going to work have you guys ever
seen the commercial for PlayStation 9 no
you guys want to see it let me play this
video for you guys
[Music]
new for 2078. that's a smart dust
PlayStation 9's new electronic scores
tap straight into your adrenal gland yep
that is legit
the ps9 has improved retinal scanning
a mind control system
a holographic movie surround vision
[Music]
telepathic personal music
[Music]
the ultimate just got better
PlayStation 9.
teleport yours today that is great why
did they think that it was going to take
five decades six decades to get to
PlayStation 9.
I have no idea yeah it's creepy though
isn't it yeah dude you're gonna be able
to do that but you're gonna have like 80
80 games going on at once in your brain
people are going to evolve to multitask
to have be able to think about different
things at the same time and you're gonna
this is gonna help train us to do that
in this day and age you can't even tell
if that's parody Or Not Like if you told
me oh this is an official uh Sony
commercial Jordan I totally believe you
I have no idea what that is but it's
separating these like parody skits from
actual reality everything is becoming so
dystopia nowadays we're just like living
in a weird Black Mirror episode when
Mark Zuckerberg shows up and says oh
you're all going to enter the metaverse
with me and we're like what is actually
going on people will do it I think most
people are going to do it I think you
know we are more likely to be the
outliers who Steve Bannon talks about it
but Steve bannon's on the older side you
you you tell a young kid they're going
to be able to actually go into The
Witcher and and live in that world
you're going to tell them your favorite
TV shows you're you're not just going to
watch the TV show you're going to be in
the room as all of that stuff is
happening you're not just going to watch
Game of Thrones okay bad example Game of
Thrones
what's what's what's what's a new hot
show Hellbound
or squid game you're not just going to
be watching squid game you're going to
be in the games running around as the
stuff is going on and get this you could
actually they could they could make
shows where you can sit and watch it
happen or you could stop things and then
choose to interact with the characters
what if we're in the VR right now what
if we're in the metaverse as we're
speaking right now
then we're not doing it very well
up and beat this I think we're doing
very well I mean I just do side quests
first okay this is aside we're still
doing side quests okay
what oh I was gonna say something
speaking of the simulation isn't that
new Matrix movie coming out in a few
days that sounds so they're gonna just
enjoy that trilogy they're gonna destroy
all the hardcore like messaging of of
freedom and liberty and against the
system they're gonna make it just I
think a total pro-establishment Pro
propaganda of our modern day blue-haired
person that's not there's literally one
of the main characters is like a
blue-haired non-binary person I remember
I was gonna say these kids you're gonna
get like a 10 year old being like okay
Mom I'm going into the metaverse and
puts on their helmet goes into their
digital shop where they're selling their
nfts and all these they're like this
really well-known salesman in the verse
and then all these people come by and
they're buying all this stuff and the
kid comes out an hour later and pays for
his parents food and and like you're
gonna have the we might see a society
where the kids are paying for the adults
via their digital presence in the verse
The Matrix got it wrong
in The Matrix they're like humans were
forced to be batteries for the machines
it should have actually been humans
chose to be batteries for the machines
because they got you know the CR it's
like the cipher character in the first
Matrix he's like eating steak and he's
like I want to be back in The Matrix but
you know I'll tell you one thing that's
going to get crazy too a lot of what
we're seeing about identity issues where
people want to be animals where people
want to be dragons or demon dolls or
whatever I mean legit we talked about
the demon doll woman she identifies as a
demon doll whatever that is yeah they're
gonna they're gonna go in the metaverse
and they're gonna be that so when that
little kid goes into his his metaverse
to sell his nfts he's gonna be like a
giant Duck and then someone's gonna walk
in and be like duck man what up let me
get some of those nfts I'll take that
one and that one all those shoes are
sick I'm gonna put them on Avatar right
now and then he blinks and then give me
a question give me a quack and then the
little kid who's the duck goes and then
the kid comes out he leaves the
metaverse and he walks into the bathroom
he looks in the mirror and just goes
and then he puts the metaverse back on
and he's the guy again so who's keeping
the lights on while we're all in the
metaverse it's going to be done via
Smart contract the government the
government's going to be taking care of
everyone everyone's going to be on the
on not only just the social credit score
but what was Andrew Yang talking about
uh you know a pentence that the
government's going to be giving you just
to live what did he call it the Ubi yeah
yeah yeah the whole the propaganda was
Freedom
dividends third and backwards
who is going to be running this thing
like is it going to be the corporation
the corporations sci-fi movie the
government working with the corporations
uh hand in hand in tandem with the
intelligence agencies calling the shots
just like they do now and they're the
same way that they do now on their own
like unique metaverse like their own
private one that isn't tracked or
something and then they're all and
they're gonna be they're going to be GMS
they're going to be moderators gonna be
admins you're going to be in the
metaverse and you're gonna be like hey
you guys want to come with me to you
know duck store to see the the new Duck
nfts and you're gonna be walking and
then Mark Zuckerberg to be walking by
and you need to go oh hey look it's
Zuckerberg and then he's just gonna turn
his head like a robot and just go and
then he's gonna you know have just
powers in the metaverse he's gonna
delete your your avatar and you're gonna
snap out and be like no I can't be here
people will work their whole lives to
become admins like I just want to be a
GM I just want to be a GM and then they
finally get it they're 35 and they
realize it's not all it's cracked up to
be the hours are long imagine being a
moderator in the metaverse like
someone's walking around in like a big
open space yelling about Flat Earth or
whatever and then a moderator shows up
and says you know like you're being
banned and then snap the person's guns
imagine imagine if in reality people had
these kinds of powers that you could be
standing in the middle of Public Square
holding up a sign saying you know you
know the end is nigh or End the Fed or
something and then a cop walks up and
says disturbing the peace snap and then
you just don't exist anymore yeah you
could have a metaverse where like one
guy you're there doing something another
guy comes up and like stop up and wants
to destroy you in the metaverse and he
destroys you but from your perspective
he explodes and so you both you both win
in your own experience being possible if
there's a centralized server but I do
think this is a really good argument for
why there needs to be if there is a
metaverse it has to be decentralized and
and this actually be a really cool thing
if there was like one big centralized
metaverse server and they've got
moderators guarding the door and they're
like you can't come in but you could go
to any other server people could host
their own private servers there'd be
crazy servers that'd be that'd be that'd
be that'd be kind of crazy I think the
problem is all of this is predicated
upon whether or not you're going to have
a hole drilled into your head and a
microchip implanted in your brain
which you will and you'll be living
under the Ubi and the social credit
score and they'll be smart dust flying
around everywhere making sure you're
compliant with it or else it'll be
injected into your body and then have
the turn off switch further have you
heard about the smart dust we've talked
about a little bit uh that's what the
PlayStation 9 commercial was all about
they released we have it right
nanoparticles yeah it's been around for
a while yep uh smart dust is a system of
many tiny Micro electromechanical
Systems mems such as sensors robots or
devices that can detect for example
light temperature vibration magnetism
chemicals they're used uh they're
they're usually operated on a computer
network wirelessly distributed over air
to form tasks blah blah they're a few
millimeters they may be vulnerable to
electromatic disablement you get the
point it's not when you say smart dust a
lot of people think it's like tiny and
you can't see it it's like nanotech for
the most part they're not saying that
right now they're saying it's very very
small sensors and computers that can be
used for you know tracking manipulating
things yeah but the technology that's
being developed along with the metaverse
I think goes hand in hand with again
what I said before the smart grid the
social credit score and I think it's
going to be crucially implemented in a
lot of the control grid systems that are
already being put into place that are
being developed thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time